these insane standards that they hold
for the right it's it's so comical too
like 2020 the Riots of 2020. they would
do everything that they could to
basically work it down if a super
violent Riot they would work it down to
just being oh it was just some people
there's like a whole parking lot on fire
and that's the standard that the police
station was burning down in the like
fiery but mostly peaceful that's where
the meme comes from like in Portland at
the Marco Hatfield federal courthouse
trying to burn down the courthouse with
federal agents inside and they're still
not reporting on it all Trump has to say
is hey go protests and that's a call for
for Action a call for violence I didn't
hear his call but what was it like if he
gets arrested he wants people on the
streets
we need to take our country back which
they also interpret as right it's so
vague like should he be more specific
like be here at this time protest
illegal uh or or unjust arrests of
presidents and things like that